ils veulent nationaliser toutes les
grandes compagnies toutes sans exception
ont été associés dans leur programme
voyons ce qui est écrit dans le
programme de québec solidaire
québec solidaire vise à long terme la
socialisation des activités économiques
cette transformation reposera notamment
sur la nationalisation des grandes
entreprises dans certains secteurs
stratégiques dans son programme
québec solidaire préconise de placer
l'industrie minière sous contrôle public
incluant au besoin la nationalisation
complète ici la même phrase pour la
grande industrie forestière
le programme de québec solidaire
mentionne également une possible
nationalisation partielle du système
bancaire il ya toutefois une nuance
entre le programme du parti et sa plate
forme
le programme c'est la vision à long
terme adoptée par les militants et la
plateforme c'est ce que québec solidaire
propose à l'ensemble des électeurs pour
le prochain mandat
la seule la chaîne isation la seule si
celle des transports interurbains et
nous on pense que l'antre l'entreprise
privée a échoué en plus du projet de
nationalisation du transport interurbain
la plateforme de q est-ce pour
l'élection 2018 propose de nationaliser
le développement de l'éolien tuer ce jeu
aussi placé sous contrôle public les
mines de lithium pour ce qui est des
mines de lithium québec solidaire dit
qu'il s'agirait d'une nationalisation
partielle
[Musique]